Why are you so kind to me, a stranger
? Yes,
you're kind, but you're a strange person. I
immediately thought that I should give him more experiences he's never had before.
[Laughter]
[Music]  ]
[Music]
You're an honest and serious person, which is rare these days.I'll
teach you what not to do in the future.What you can't do means you
shouldn't do bad things.Me and
Charlotte, Magic Knight Apprentice Elka Crafoda.  I'm going to
teach you what not to do to be cute, so you're the delivery guy at Tapiros Transporter Nya Nya What's the wrong thing to do? I wonder if you
can protect Charlotte Evans Yes, you
can't satisfy Chili either. Is that just a decoration?
[Music]
Karen-san  I'll
give you the love that makes my heart flutter. It's so
beautiful that you can't help but smile.
When you're happy, this level of happiness makes you laugh.
This is just the beginning. From now on, I'll
teach you all the pleasures of this world.  Even if you
cry or scream, I won't show you mercy. I'll
teach you that it's wrong for me to pick up a young lady whose engagement has been broken.
Broadcast starts in October 2023 You can watch it, you ca
n't watch it.